ان نتابع مع الساده المشاهدين هذه الصور
الحصريه عبر شاشه قناه العربيه من قاعده
مروي التي تدور فيها اشتباكات حاليا بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اذا هذه الصور حصريه مشاهدينا لقناه
العربيه من مدينه مروي في شمال السودان في
منطقه مروي التي تشهد اشتباكاتنا عنيفه في
محيط القاعده الجويه ايضا قاعده مروي
العسكريه اذا هي صور الشبكه عنيفه نشاهد
فيها من على البعد اعمده الدخان وهي
تتصاعد مراسل العربيه ذكر قبل قليل ان
هناك حاله من الخوف والهلع ان تابت سكان
المدينه بداوا في اخلاء الاسواق واخلاء
الشوارع وهناك انتشار كثيف الاجهزه
الامنيه
لقوات الجيش نذكر بان قوه الدعم السريع
مشاهدينا قد نفذت انتشارا واستخدم
التعزيزات كبيره الى هذه المدينه قبل
يومين وهو ما فاقم التوترات وصعد من حده
الخطاب الموجه بين الطرفين
اذا هذه صور ترصدها كاميرا العربيه وصور
حصريه للوضع في محيط قاعده مروي العسكريه
التي تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه حاليا بين قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات